It can be articulated speech on ways that people stretch themselves out and
dreams can shed light on things that sometimes it might take you a decade to
figure out because dreams are the birthplace of thought.
It's not like fully articulated thoughts.
Just hear in your head and no development in history.
First of all,
we don't really know how thoughts appear in your head at all.
It's a mystery,
but it's certainly the case that they just arise out of the dream is part of the
process by which the thoughts emerge.
So you could say that the dream stands in the same relationship to your thought
that art stands in relationship to a culture.
Same thing.
Or you can say that dream stand in the same relationship to your thought.
As religious imagery stands in relationship to the culture.
The religious imagery of your culture is like this dream to interview,
and so I've had lots of clients like I didn't do dream work with all my clients
because not all my clients remember the dreams,
but some of them remember that three or four nights and we would assess them,
discuss them,
talk them through trying to make sense of the cost.
Often I believe so it's down here.
There's another thing that's really interesting.
Dreams is you know,
because you don't really have conscious control over them.
They don't live in I.
Whatever a dream tells you this is the truth.
You might not be able to understanding just the dream is trying to be mystical
or anything like that.
It's that the dream is trying to express something that you don't fully
understand it in the best possible way.
That you can understand that as a NAC and that might not be very good,
but it's accurate,
is a dream is something that comes directly from nature.
It's not you.
It's more like it's something that happens to you.
It's worth paying attention.
You can learn a lot from frames.
It's not simple,
but sometimes it is,
sometimes what they need is clear,
but it's also the case.
The more you work on them,
the deeper they get.
So yeah,
and you could see around corners,
but it's not that surprising,
as I said,
the purpose of thoughts to be pathetic prepare you for
I'm from the Soviet Union and a lot of your commentary about the tyranny and the
vomit that took place there helped healthy process a lot of,
um,
you know,
my best memories of something that I'm going to ask is how do I make peace with
the fact that most,
a lot of the victims of the Soviet theory under the communist tyranny and in
other countries,
we're also the ones that brought it on themselves as Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn.
Uh,
you know,
the conclusion he came to in the Gulag archipelago.
I mean,
the one hand,
it's like,
I mean angry at,
at the communist regimes and the members of my own family were murdered by the
Stalin regime for speaking out of him.
But,
but then a lot of the other ones,
it was the regime they brought to power
the book
itself.
I think generally
it's good to include yourself in that group,
know he used to say that he'd sort of thrown off the ideological
that him and his compatriots were played comrades,
newly imprison diehard communists and quiz them about all the inadequacies and
corruptions of the state,
and of course they would just lay out their ideological routine and it was like
a satirical gate.
No,
from Solzhenitsyn Solzhenitsyn's perspective where you sit,
it's like,
it's like walking in a desert talking to someone like that.
He said he made the rounds of the smithies and came home on shot the same thing,
but social.
This attitude essentially wasn't it.
As soon as someone who was a partial perpetrator and then trapped by the system,
realized their complicitness in the system that they can be brought back into
the full.
And I think that's an extension.
It's really an extension of a Christian idea.
That's the idea of something like confession and redemption.
You know?
It's like,
well,
when do you make peace with someone?
When they admit to their error,
that's when you can forgive.
So you know,
because you say,
well,
forgiveness is a virtue.
It's it is,
but it isn't a preconditioned list for truth,
right?
You want to pull people back into the full.
They have to abandon that which
knocked them off the path before you do that same name if you're trying to make
peace with yourself,
so that's how it how it looks to me like
everybody is oppressed and oppressor situation like that.
When people are.
When people repent of the oppression,
you hold them back in full or something like that,
like conspiracy theories and many,
many other things.
They're not entirely doing that just to defame you.
I think they really like what's going on in universities is so absurd.
It
there's an entire sub branch of feminism and feminist purely devoted to
dismantling science itself is corrupt in patriarchal.
When this happened in Canada,
now first of all,
the press as a whole,
we're not laid out.
What was happening to spill
response was,
well,
you're saying there's something wrong with our system.
Our system works fine.
There must be something wrong with
99 percent of circumstances and maybe it's the right response to whistleblowers
in general.
It depends on the system.
You know,
and so it's also even reasonable if you stand up and object to something that's
happened legislatively for people to say,
well,
how do we know you're not crazy?
You're crazy like this or like this or like this,
you.
It's a lot of accusations.
I wouldn't necessarily say it's the best way of conducting the debate,
but it's not surprising.
So.
So first of all,
it's an exploratory tactic and separate courses.
It's in the best interests of people who was trying to this math and science to
pay.
He has sufficiently reprehensible along some dimension so that I should be
attended to because if I'm not a terrible creature and unreasonable,
then there's something wrong with what they're doing so I can be reasonable.
And so unfortunately I am reasonably.
They really knew things were happening that they would have listened to you,
but
believe it or not believable.
I mean there's a great thing happening in Canada right now as far as I'm
concerned.
So I don't know how many of you were aware of what happened.
Wilfrid laurier university,
amazing.
The most.
The biggest scam ever hit a Canadian university and I think,
I think they have no idea how many people know about because wherever I go
Australia,
the United Kingdom Hall and people know about this case,
she's suing the university
because I'm really in touch with the lawyer.
I'm going to go after them as well,
so I'm going to read the statement of claim on my youtube channel problem
tomorrow.
A
lawyer of planning actually reads like a,
like a normal.
So you know,
they,
they went after her carer and she taped it,
but then,
well then there's a bunch of things that happen.
So they claimed that is due to the motor class was a lie.
No student complaint.
What happened was somebody in the diversity office overheard some students talk
about the class and complaint.
That's not the same because students,
especially when you say that a student.
Right.
Okay.
So the university apologized and professor apologized.
He sort of apologized,
but we'll see next year and it's all documented.
Like they didn't learn it as thing and you read this statement of playing.
They started.
It's not like there's who is informed mistakes the university made.
It's like physically,
you just can't believe that.
It's very engrossing.
I'm looking.
I'm really actually looking forward
to see engrossing and.
But you can't believe that which is of course why the recording she made caused
such a stir.
It's like,
really?
Really?
This is happening.
It's like,
no,
you don't understand that it's happening.
It's standard practice.
It's not an normally.
Oh yeah,
it's everywhere.
It's absolutely.
It's absolutely unbelievable,
but what's even more unbelievable is when you call people out for it,
which is what happened,
and Wilfrid Laurier,
it makes no difference.
They don't learn a thing.
They didn't learn the things they're going to be scattered is the scattering is
not going to go away.
It's to.
It's about to get way worse.
I suspect that by the time it's older,
both professors will be fired in the president of the university will reside.
That's my gifts.
Were hoping that would be the case and maybe that will actually.
This is why I wasn't going to take legal action,
but what's Lindsey decided to the lawyer who was a good lawyer and putting the
fish's character,
which is part of what makes a good lawyer.
He sent me the statement in any aspect you want to join,
do you want to join the claim?
And I said,
well,
why don't you write about.
I'll read it,
and so you wrote it up when I read it,
the outlines,
all of the things that you accused me of and it's just.
It's absolutely.
If you just generated the laundry list of things,
you could hypothetically accused someone.
All of them are there,
so it starts with hepburn
kind of does the trick for the cakes because you're going to defame someone.
A good old Hitler comparison.
There's a lovely
day and then they compared compared to be in the mind of
the
professor said
is like playing a video bio Hitler or Milo.
You slipped in a sentence like that and you think everything that's wrong with
you is encapsulated
insults.
You can't have both of those in the same sense,
right?
You're like the worst mass murder in history or a provocative gate.
British Jews.
One of the things that we'll see,
I have a bit of trepidation because the court system in Canada are also being
more white,
but I don't think you're.
And there's the case law school as well,
which is really terrible thing and that's happened to us.
Very,
very proud.
But
yeah,
it's not surprising.
It's not surprising.
When I started,
you know,
criticized this building.
The other thing about the mail that was so strange was like if you read the bill
itself,
this has really contributed to the public confusion.
It's only about two paragraphs long and what's in the bill doesn't look unless
you really think about it doesn't look dangerous,
but there's a set of policies within which the bill was going to be interpreted.
The federal government in Maryland and I read the policies and the policies are
just.
They're just,
you just can't believe that exists.
We've written a social constructionist view of gender into Canadian law.
It's like,
what the hell?
It's like lysenkoism in Sophia.
Well,
that's the other thing that I said that the Senate,
it's like,
okay,
this is your argument.
Gender is socially constructed,
but a manager manageably born in a woman's body.
That's your argument.
I understand that.
That argument makes no sense.
You can't have the biological determinism of the wrong body with the claim of
social constructionism of gender irrelevant.
You're making the assumption that logical coherence magnets in the debate like
this and it doesn't.
That's just part of the patriarchal structure.
How do you handle it when the opposition doesn't pair,
if anything actually make sense or not,
or rather what they say is true with.
Well,
I think I think that.
I think partly what you do is try to expose that.
One of the things I've learned,
I've learned a couple of things over the last couple of years of dealing with
this situation.
The first thing I learned that this would be a lovely.
You can all learn this,
but what I'm telling you help a lot.
It really does work,
so there's an English common law principle that I outlined in rule five,
which is don't make your children do anything that makes you dislike them.
It's the doctor of never minimal necessary force and you have the right under
English common law to defend yourself with minimum necessary for us.
But what I've learned is that's actually the right amount of force to defend
yourself optimally.
And so if you're attacked by people who are from Aaron's,
let's say,
and with a strong antipathy towards you,
the best thing to do is to back off and just let them lay out your cap.
Especially if you're going to be publicly.
Because all it does expose the structure of their arguments.
And when that's happened to me,
as long as I've kept my temporary,
which I've done 95 percent of the time.
Then all the consequences of that is that the person who brings forth the
accusatory argument loses every time and not just a little bit either like it's
been.
And so,
and,
and I've watched because I pay attention to the comments that people make and I
pay attention to the means that people generate to keep an eye on the
temperature stays.
The memes are actually really helpful because as long as they're humorous,
you know,
like you're poking fun at and it's Siriko but it's not,
I'm time,
it's just sitting for and,
and you know that that comic edge is a really good thing because as long as,
as long as you can take a joke,
you're probably not a tyrant and as long as you can take a jokes,
joke,
the jokes don't get too cruel and so it's a very good thing to watch.
And so I've tried to keep my tamper but the doctrine of minimum necessary
forest,
that's unbelievably useful.
Don't push back with any more forced than is minimally necessary.
It really works.
It really is.
It's a kin to the turn the other cheek.
It's very,
very closely aligned to that.
And so,
you know,
on the other thing,
I do believe that public discourse works.
And so,
you know,
when the university went after me,
he wrote me two letters telling me to stalk,
which was actually really good because I said that when I made the videos I said
they're probably already illegal to make these criticized critical videos and
everybody jumped out of the woodwork and said,
you're being paranoid.
And then the university,
thankfully he had there been lawyers review what I did compensate conclusion and
sent me these two letters I just read.
I just read them without comments here.
And so my sense has been my experience has been that if people,
first of all,
people are basically reasonable,
like the founders of your constitution are correct.
People are reasonable fundament,
some people aren't reasonable at all and they're noisy and sometimes they
dominate,
but the bulk of people you can rely on it.
And so if you inform everyone about what's going on,
then the majority comes to the appropriate conclusion.
That's how it looks to me.
I think you can have faith in that.
And so,
and I've had way more support.
The criticism is not even 100 to 1:50,
101,
something like that.
So I guess it just makes me a little nervous,
but like we've said multiple times that they like praying on a religious
substructure sort of fulfilled and if that's enough to convince people to one of
your talks,
they were like banging on the windows.
Oh yeah,
that was a Roman.
If that's enough to do that.
Like what's to stop 1776 from being necessary a second.
Yeah.
Well I have very tiny minority and I think that.
I think that good sense prevailed.
I do believe though
that the states you'd be polarizing before
the stakes were higher,
but you were polarized around,
around when Nixon was president,
there were stretched pretty far apart.
You got through that.
You've been through worse than this.
I think Tom Hanson will prevail.
I also think the universities are way
things are going to flip upside down with the university so fast that it'll be a
shot.
Well,
they're much my question doing what corporations do.
Like let's say that you're busy and you've built up a great brand,
people trust,
right?
Because you produce high quality content for years,
so you have the Disney brand and then some people come in and take over the
company and they just start dumping on
and then,
well that would work for about three years and then you've sucked all the value
out of the brand and that's it.
Little trusted anymore.
I think it is brand break.
You know you've got,
you've got an incredible reputation and then you could explain the hell out of
pocket.
I think that that's the universities is that they haven't brand and the brand is
the universities are the liberal arts,
the sciences,
technology that can survive on its own,
the liberal,
the liberal arts or the university.
The liberal arts are valuable because they teach people wisdom.
If you stopped being DP,
teaching people wisdom,
the wisdom isn't gonna go away.
Someone else is gonna.
Pick up the value that start to disseminate and that'll happen electronically.
So fast can make people's heads are and I think that's what's going to happen
because I think it's possible.
It's partly why I'm working on diversity.
I think it's possible to deliver educational resources at 10 times the rate at
100 footfalls,
no administrative overhead and with accurate assessment,
I really think that's where
we'll start with the
church or exactly what the lectures that I put online.
It's like,
why wouldn't I put lectures online?
No,
I thought about going back to teaching,
which is unlikely because why would I go back to teaching 50 people who are sort
of okay about being there
overload when I can do a lecture on anything I want
and the only people that will listen or people who want to listen and there's at
least $350,000.
There's no comparison.
Absolutely no comparison.
So
this is the beginning of three really smart people working on it and they're fun
to work with because they go find ways of doing things 100 times faster and if
you're quite computer literate and theory,
computer literate and you're interested in handling information,
you can handle the information so fast is just beyond belief.
So one of the things we thought about doing it was one of the things that
universities do is this,
right?
It's like,
well,
how much do you know what
to tell you,
what you know,
which is useful,
but also to tell other people what you know,
that's your brain.
Say that the greatest systems like Max necessarily.
So we thought,
well why don't we put together a universal set of questions covering every topic
we can possibly think of so that you can and then group them so that you can go
in and just assess herself,
will rank the questions by difficulty.
You want to know how much you knew about a cell biology.
It's like,
okay,
here's a.
here's 200 questions on cell biology ranked from everyone can get it to no one
can get it,
will test you.
We'll give you your percentile.
You'll know exactly what you know and don't know and we'll collect all the
questions you don't know and you'll have a source for each of them so you can
find the answers.
In Vermont we collected 15,000 questions and sorted all of them because we found
a question database that someone in order to put together with a methodology for
generating more questions so we can generally figure we can generate $150,000 a
month and choice questions for Ken Council.
It's unbelievable.
And then we found another program that classify as content by wikipedia
knowledge structure.
So wikipedia is already laid out the universal structure essentially.
And so this thing will classify all the questions immediately so we can just be
questions and as fast as possible and it sorts them all by,
by topic and not just main time,
main topic and subsidiary.
So we figured in three months you can have 150,000 questions ready so that
everybody can assess what they know on everything there is to be known at work.
So
I asked him to do things,
well,
first of all,
we're going to figure out how to do it 100 times faster.
And with computers you can do everything fast.
And so there's lots of people who want to fund this.
And then we started to think about,
we want to teach people to read,
we want to teach them to write,
I'm going to outsource the problem of grading is learning to write and reading
the problem with feedback in ways in solving that.
But I think that I think the universities are way more gave me.
I really believe that especially because the only thing that they really offer
all the economic value of a university degrees in the accreditation,
not in the education.
So,
so,
so that that's a different thing that,
I mean the economic value for the employer because they want to know,
like if you're a Harvard graduate,
the reason that you're valuable isn't because you're graduating from arc.
It's because it's impossible to get into Harvard.
Right?
And then the documentation on this is clear.
If you look at most educational institutions,
the reason that the graduates are valuable isn't because of what they learned in
the institution.
It's,
it depends on how good the accreditation system was in screening people before
they went to the institution.
So for example,
if you go to an executive MBA program at a high level university,
you have to write the uh,
it's the standardized tests that they use for business school
over the team out.
And so if it's a high end school,
you have to score like 99th percentile.
Well that's actually why you're valuable as a graduate.
It's because you scored 90,
90 percent.
The Gi map,
what they teach you in business school,
it's like it's not that use and the blood of business schools know this.
I've talked to lots of,
they're absolutely aware of it and so I think it will be possible to steal
accreditation from the universities and,
and also do steel it in a way that cannot be gerrymandered it sexual race
ethnicity,
not like you'll get your damn great and it will say how much you knows and that
repeat that.
And so there will be tremendous value in that because what people need is solid
accreditation.
So that's the problem we're solving first.
So when you knock them out with assistance,
you know,
like the higher education system,
you leave the value behind.
Let's say you need to know you have a classical education behind,
someone's going to pick up that value when an offer it because the values are
underneath there,
so I think the universities I calculated the other day,
they were making seven fatal errors and I've seen big businesses go out of
business and they can run a business really,
really,
really fat.
It's really quite staggering of things could journal,
you know,
in the universities they're way too top heavy administrative way.
It's gone way out of kilter over the last three decades and it's not faculty
costs.
That's mistake number one.
Mistake number two is their gerrymandering.
The accreditation process.
That's a big mistake.
Number three,
they're not teaching people to write into safe mistake.
Number four there,
especially in the US,
they figured out,
ever pick the pockets of students future earnings and condemn them to indentured
servitude,
right?
That's what the non bankruptcy student loan program has done and that's feeding
the administrative top heaviness.
Next fatal error.
Fifth layer ethics committees are killing research by just slowing it down so
much.
It's too damn painful to do human research and they're also producing
generations of scientists and lie because in order to circumvent the idiot
ethics committees,
you have to do all sorts of sideways things so that you can move your research
forward with any degree of deficiency.
So that was six.
Well the last thing they're doing is they're using the wrong criteria
increasingly to select your own selector.
They're faculty,
but the last thing is they're replacing full time faculty with adjuncts,
so instead of instead of full time faculty who are tenured,
who might dispute utility of tenure,
but it hasn't seemed ability,
they're hiring part time people.
They don't pay them anything.
Right?
They exploited because they don't pay the mirroring what they're working on.
They have zero power zero and they can't make any administrative decisions,
so it's perfect for the administrator like no too many states have no.
There's no way you're going to stumble and then you get a situation like the
situation at Harvard.
It's like,
no,
they're taking half as many Asian students as they should take.
It's like,
really?
It isn't.
It's like who cares if it's unfair?
I mean,
I care,
but that's not the problem.
The problem is if you have students who score at the 99th percentile on their
sats and they've done everything else you would need to do to go our Hartford,
which would be.
You'd have to be good at it,
at least two other things that kids need.
The grades you need to use in.
You have to be good to do other things.
It's like there aren't many people like that.
You want to take those people and you want to put them in place where they get
the best possible education and the reason you want to do that isn't because
it's fair to them.
It's because you want to exploit the hell out of them for the rest of their life
because they're going to do your society a tremendous amount of good.
If you're too damn stupid to give them the proper opportunity,
then all you're going to do is not hell out of your whole society.
It's like it isn't unfair to the Asian students.
Even though it is.
That's not the point.
It's the.
You're going to let a resource like that go to waste.
Are you out of your mind?
These people are like one in a thousand,
something like that.
Don't waste them.
Right?
And so.
And they are lasting.
So that's not,
that's not smart.
We think with our accreditation system,
so imagine this,
so we'll have thousand mathematics questions.
So then we can have people take the questions from stratified by age.
Say,
all right,
here's,
you can take the data and say here's the top scores in the 15 to 17 year old
category.
Maybe there's a thousand kids who took it.
Maybe there's five.
So we can take the top 100.
You can say here's the email addresses of the other top 100.
So now all of a sudden you guys who were like mathematically mathematical
geniuses on the order,
the first percentile say now you have a peer group.
Same with physics,
engineering and biology to be able to network with people that are like hyper
smart and then they can go off and do whatever networks of hyper smart people
do,
which is generally push each other and compete like app.
And so anyways,
so that's part of it I guess I think,
but there's lots of people who want to fund this.
I'm trying to figure out,
you don't want to just raise a bunch of money because money is a problem as well
as a solution because once you have a bunch of money,
you have to figure out how to handle it intelligent.
That's a little more difficult than your company.
And the business partner told me it's really easy to grow your business on the
cost side.
Right?
And so
I think what we're probably going to do is because there's so many people
telling me,
probably a half dozen people tonight to have an opportunity to participate in.
Some of that might be financial,
some of them might be in terms of content,
but we're going to try to crack that over the next three or four months.
So I think
when,
when technology's changing this rap,
you abandoned your responsibility to do something important at your peril
because there's plenty of ways that you can be replaced that.
And you know,
the other thing too is that universities now are only a tiny proportion of
people can be educated.
They might be able to increase that by a factor and teach people all over the
world.
Obviously youtube videos and podcasts and all that.
So I'm not so worried.
No,
not to any great degree.
So worried what I do see,
like the European Union date,
curse them,
decided that they haven't actually passed this law yet,
but it's part of a proposition.
It's a set of propositions that they're attempting to move into law,
that if you're going to have a website,
you're going to have to use,
you would have to implement ai to screen your content for hate speech.
First of all,
you have to implement the air.
That's one butt cheek second.
The Ai has to be able to identify it.
That's not even.
First of all,
hate speech is the category that we have an AI system can learn.
We can't even agree on it.
So again,
AI system can't learn to categorize something that we can't categorize.
So it's the EU,
the European Union.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So,
so the,
the,
the censorship thing is worrisome,
but it's not so easy to censor Internet geniuses and they tend to stay one step
ahead of the bureaucrats,
you know,
and there's lots of people in Silicon Valley who are already watching the
censorship problem and thinking,
well here's a bunch of reasons we can deal with very quickly.
So,
so
John Taylor Gatto
deliberate dumbing down of the US a lot of votes on the Prussian education
system and design to have a gun.
The marketing class,
it's really good at serving in the military and that's what Americans really
good at.
I don't think that's conspiratorial,
but I think behind that would interfere with some random.
There's no,
I don't,
I think that there's no date and never assume a level of stupidity,
but because stupidities it's a much better explanation for most things.
See what happened with Prussian education system.
There was actually a reason,
you know,
I mean,
first of all,
in that time,
in that place,
one of the real man's was how to have a viable military and what to do with
underemployed young men and that she was making them into soldiers and the
pressures get that very effective in other European states that wanted them to
protect the military and then use that as an system.
And so
looking back you think,
well that's kind of reprehensible in imagery and it is by today's standards,
it is part of course.
Back then in the US,
the idea was more rural.
People were moving to the cities on mice and things were starting to
industrialize and that can be two problems.
One was how do you ensure a steady pool of labor for the industrialized future,
reasonable problem and what to do with the children of the people who were
working in factories announced was
put them in factory training school and that was the public education system and
that was reasonable because the probability that those kids were going to be
working in factories was high.
What's unreasonable?
This is what is that?
That hasn't changed 100 years later.
Right now I don't.
I don't think.
I've never met anyone who's powerful,
who is motivated to keep people stupid.
Most of the people I know that are powerful and cognitive are very annoyed
as educated and competent as they could be because they're starving for educated
and competent and so I don't.
I think that people might interfere with a real education system out of
ignorance and maybe out of India,
Lord,
but I don't think any,
and I don't think it'll matter because I don't think of your grass can control
computer technology.
It's so fast and so many people in that field are so smart and if you're a
computation wisdom,
it's like bureaucrats there.
You're in 2050 and there in 1942.
They're not in the same way over time.
No,
we've been as
well.
We're brothers on the road one.
It was a pleasure talking to all of you and thank you for very nice.